c'est ici que d'après audrey rémy aurait
surgi masqués et armés ils étaient seuls
dès qu'il a il est rentré il ya tué dans
le don s'il a eu le temps de se
retourner il a compris que ce qui se
passait c'est sûr qu'elle a dû le faire
on souffrira il a dû voir cela et
surtout p
nous sommes sur l'étang de thau à côté
de sète dans l'hérault
c'est ici que marquise war vient tous
les jours travailler sur ces parcs à
huîtres et trouver un peu d'apaisement
car malgré ce cadre idyllique marque ne
se remet pas de l'assassinât de son
frère patrick il ya trois ans
j'aurais jamais cru que lui mais ils
partent comment ça
s'était
jamais jamais jamais j'aurais pas
laisser un
d'ailleurs quand à juillet quand il a
disparu âgé mais qu'est ce qui lui est
arrivé il s'est trouvé au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
depuis le drame l'ostréiculteur
entretient la mémoire de patrick mort
brutalement à 49 ans
au mas où il travaille avec sa fille
nelly qui aimait beaucoup son oncle les
souvenirs sont partout
ça
ça c'est lui et moi il avait 8 ans j'en
avais 13 ans
ça c'est mon frère là avec mes filles sa
fille a hélas et ça se passe le 15 juin
il est mort le 23 le pont c'est la
dernière photo de votre frère
du joueur avec lequel j'ai joué
c'est dur quand quand on remet beaucoup
de choses comme ça
après bon d'en parler on en parle après
ben voilà c'est pas des discussions qui
sont mes seins
c'est dur de wade de tourner
c'était le 17 juillet 2014
le corps de patrick is war chauffeur
livreur pour l'hôpital de sète est
découvert dans une grotte en pleine
ville
il a été retrouvé ligoté abattu de deux
balles de fusil de chasse et en partie
calciné dans une galerie souterraine du
mont saint clair le crime ressemble à un
règlement de comptes mais va prendre une
toute autre tournure quand deux ans plus
tard un homme et une femme sont arrêtés
un coiffeur sétois soupçonnée d'avoir
agi par jalousie amoureuse est une jeune
femme qui aurait servi d'appât
pour certains le coiffeur n'en serait
pas à son coup d'essai il crie son
innocence
que s'est il réellement passé dans le
huis clos de cette grotte retour sur une
affaire où se mêlent vengeance et
machiavélisme et dans laquelle trois
familles se déchirent pour faire
entendre leur vérité
le 23 juin 2014 vers 16h15 patrick isoir
quitte son travail comme tous les jours
après son service à l'hôpital
avant de partir il a confié à ses
collègues qu'il a un rendez vous galant
avec une jeune femme
il ne donnera plus jamais signe de vie
dès le lendemain matin son frère marc se
lance à sa recherche et découvre son
scooter garé à côté du cimetière à
quelques centaines de mètres de
l'hôpital voilà la même face à aux
panneaux
et à l'intérieur on découvre la casca le
blouson son paquet de cigarettes le
téléphone à
pourquoi partir en laissant ses affaires
dans la petite ville c'est
l'incompréhension
divorcé et père d'une petite fille
patrick isoir n'avait aucune raison de
disparaître et pas d'ennemi connu comme
nous confirme delphine sa meilleure amie
qui travaillait avec lui à l'hôpital
patrick était connue
dans le centre
à la pointe courte il était mêlé michaud
carte il aimait choix la pétanque qu'il
aimait faire les apéros est un bon
vivant
à cette personne ne croit à une
disparition volontaire de patrick
en cherchant dans son téléphone son
frère découvre un numéro mystérieux et
décide de l'appeler c'est une femme
fini ces trois cas y aura deux niveaux
et mon frère là le m'a dit oui m'a dit
j'ai quelque chose est fait elle m'a dit
allez rester devant le cimetière on a
parlé pour les partis chacun d'un côté
je vous ai disputé qua non non non non
non je n'ai pas disputé une partie
japonaise cotée à
la jeune femme avec qui patrick avaient
rendez-vous avant sa disparition
s'appelle audrey elle a 20 ans de moins
que lui c'est une ancienne conquête
patrick et elle avait une courte
aventure six ans plus tôt
après des années de silence audrey
venait tout juste de reprendre contact
avec lui
flatté patrick en avait même parlé à son
ami philippe lors d'une partie de cartes
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone et
j'aimerais que tu entendes
fait écouter c'est une femme elle ne
voit très mielleuse très doux ça qui me
disait qu'elle nourrit bien le revoir
dans un café
discuter m'a dit qu'après se voit lui
dit tu dis la vérité je pèse ou qu'elle
veut pas que le café et vous tu
arriveras elle m'a dit c'est que je
pense et je me dis jérémy a confirmé je
vois que tu me confiera il m'a dit c'est
bizarre ils me disent ça fait des années
que je la voyais plus et du jeune homme
elle m'appelle elle me poserai les
moutons c'est ce qu'on croit
sans nouvelles depuis 48 heures marquise
war déclare la disparition de son frère
au commissariat une enquête est ouverte
audrey est entendue et va donner plus de
précisions sur sa rencontre avec son ex
amant
nostalgique elle a proposé à patrick de
le revoir lui fixant rendez-vous à côté
du cimetière
c'est un de ses amis proches rémy
coiffeur à domicile qui l'aurait déposé
en voiture en allant travailler
elle aurait passé 20 minutes à discuter
de tout et de rien avec patrick à côté
du scooter puis elle serait rentrée chez
elle
audrey rémy sont les derniers à avoir vu
patrick ils sont placés en garde à vue
face aux policiers ils sont catégoriques
ils n'ont rien à voir dans sa
disparition après 48 heures
d'interrogatoire ils ressortent libres
dix jours plus tard le corps de patrick
is war est découvert par les policiers
au fond de cette grotte en pleine ville
à quelques centaines de mètres du lieu
de son rendez vous avec audrey
alors là c'est l'horreur on pense que
voilà on est passé à côté de la grotte
peut-être
300 400 500 fois et qu'il était là et
que et qu'on ne savait pas
en apprenant les circonstances atroces
du crime ses amis sont sous le choc
s'acharner sur lui mais aussi de le
faire parler on l'a ligotée on a tiré
une balle dans l'épaule puis puis on
s'est acharné
et puis chair brûlée a le corps
c'est terrible
rapidement l'enquêté s'oriente vers un
mobile passionnel les policiers
découvrent qu'en 2009 5 ans avant le
drame patrick avait eu une liaison avec
une certaine nadège les pousses de rémy
le coiffeur une liaison qui avait fini
tragiquement
car la jeune femme de 38 ans s'était
pendu après avoir avoué son aventure
extra conjugale à son époux
à l'époque le mari de nadège avait été
entendue par les policiers
voici ce qui est écrit dans le rapport
à l'époque rémy avait déclaré aux
policiers que sa femme la veille de son
suicide lui avait avoué qu'au cours
d'une soirée arrosée entre collègues
elle l'avait trompé avec patrick is war
alors cinq ans plus tard le coiffeur se
serait-il venger de l'amant de sa femme
à l'autre bout de la france en normandie
sur la côte de nacre le père de nadège
rené chicard et son épouse colette sont
persuadés que rémy laurentien jambre est
un meurtrier
je te souhaite plus toi le fête des
pères en espérant que vous allez bien or
pour nous tout va bien je vous embrasse
la neige
cette carte c'est la dernière qu'il a
reçu de sa fille
quinze jours avant sa mort
les retraités sont persuadés que nadège
ne s'est pas suicidé mais que c'est rémy
son mari qui l'a tué et à maquiller sa
mort en suicide
un des éléments qui les a le plus
troublé c'est le mot d'adieu que nadège
a écrit à son époux avant de mourir ce
mot le voici
c'était pas une lettre de suicide la
mère m'a pas qu'à l'aller suicide et
déjà eu elle raconte seulement la soirée
qu'elle avait vécu
le comment avec patrick is war ce qui
s'était passé la relation sexuelle et
tout mais elle employait des mots mais
alors ça me déprime nadège elle parle
pas du tout sa fille rien mais non c'est
sa lé métro d'affilée lors elle aurait
dû elle aurait écrit s'il s'était
suicidé d'elle-même voilà sur la
contrainte avant de free s'est passé oui
autre chose choc rené chicard rémy n'a
prévenu aucun membre de la famille du
décès de nadège il a fait incinérer cinq
jours plus tard
comme pour effacer des traces
compromettantes selon lui
pour ma vie absolument parfait
pendant des années rené a tenté de faire
ouvrir une enquête sur la mort de sa
fille en vain
voilà toutes les lettres qu'on a faits
au tribunal de grande instance au
procureur au mois d'août au mois
d'octobre décembre janvier il ya la
santé pour commander j'ai tous les reçus
je pense que moi j'ai fait mon travail
personne n'a voulu m'écouter donc si on
m'avait écouté c'est sûr et certain
monsieur isoir fréquemment
à 7 les proches de patrick is war sont
persuadées de l'implication de rémy le
coiffeur et de son amie audrey dans
l'assassinât
marquise war multiplient les appels à
témoins dans la région et dans les
médias et l'un d'entre eux va relancer
l' enquête deux ans après les faits une
amie d'audrey raconte aux policiers
qu'elle lui a confié avoir été manipulé
par rémy pour entraîner patrick dans la
grotte
[Musique]
elle m'a dit qu'elle avait rendez vous
avec patrick pour qu'ils acceptent
d'aller dans la grotte elle lui a
proposé de lui faire une gâterie il a
accepté en arrivant de mecs l'attendait
un autre élément intrigue les policiers
dans les relevés téléphoniques de audrey
il découvre qu'à chaque fois qu'elle
appelle patrick is war quelques minutes
après elle téléphone à rémy le coiffeur
comme pour lui rendre compte de ses
conversations avec la future victime
deux ans après le drame audrey et rémy
sont interpellés et mis en examen pour
assassinat
il nie toute implication
mais six mois plus tard la jeune femme
fait des aveux à la demande du coiffeur
elle aurait entraîné patrick dans un
guet-apens prétextant un rendez vous
galant
le 23 juin 2014 rémy l'aurait donc
déposé au lieu du rendez vous
elle aurait ensuite proposé à patrick de
marcher jusqu'à la grotte
mais je ne t'arrive incombe au sahara
ils sont ils sont descendus et ils sont
rentrés
c'est ici que d'après audrey rémy aurait
surgi masqués et armés ils étaient seuls
elle ne parle plus d'un deuxième homme
cette fois ci le coiffeur lui aurait
ordonné de partir elle n'aurait donc
rien vu de la suite de l'agression lui
il attendait à il attend dé moi je pense
qu'il a tapé le fusil quoi dire qu'il a
il est rentré il a tiré dans le dos s'il
a eu le temps de se retourner il a
compris gosse ce qui se passait
[Musique]
c'est sûr qu'elle a dû le faire souffrir
il a dû voir ce voyageur toupet
depuis un an qu'il est incarcéré rémy se
dit innocent il affirme qu audrey mans
et qu'elle s'est servi de lui pour lui
faire porter le chapeau
à 7 dans l'entourage du coiffeur on est
persuadé de son innocence
sa mère sa compagne et sa fille ont
monté un comité de soutien aujourd'hui
ils sont une quinzaine à se réunir pour
eux le coiffeur est incapable d'un tel
machiavélisme rémy à 8 design est jamais
revenu de l'école l'on disait intel m'a
fait telle chose je vais me venger
jamais
bon ménage
pour laurine sa fille unique la
situation est particulièrement difficile
après avoir perdu sa mère à 11 ans son
père est accusé du pire
en dessous on soupçonne mon père du
meurtre patrie d or et ensuite de ma
mère alors qu'il a complètement rien à
voir on avait il à me refait sa vie
je m'entendais très bien avec ma belle
mère céline on s'entendait tous très
bien il y avait bien avant il peut pas
avoir fait ça moi je me dis que la star
ait dû fermer 20 ans et dans quelques
mois hier est ce que ne pas être
il y à un mois audrey et rémy se sont
retrouvés pour la première fois face à
face dans le bureau du juge à
montpellier au fil du temps audrey a
régulièrement fait évoluer son
témoignage pour les avocats du coiffeur
c'est la preuve qu'elle a tout inventé
el assir ou des choses qui ne sont pas
possibles qui ne sont pas crédibles d'un
point de vue ballistix est aberrant ce
qu'elle dit qu'elle ne voit pas de fusil
puis elle voit un fusil et non pas ta
n'entend pas trop de feu elle parle de
deux complices à lui parle d'un noir
d'un blanc s'est dit oui complet
il est venu avec un masque masque de
scream pour se cacher on est dans un
film c'est le film blood rénové il ya
absolument rien de crédible dans tout ça
pour l'avocat de la jeune femme en
revanche sa cliente a été utilisé à son
insu c'est une fille simple qui n'est
pas du tout une amende 1 tortueuse
compliqué il le niveau intellectuel
exceptionnel c'est le contraire de
quelqu'un qui manipulent aurait qui
imaginerait des scénarios vraisemblables
que le jouer tout simplement voilà a été
la pa qui a permis de
conduire ce malheureux sa destination
finale
l'instruction est toujours en cours
à ce jour l'assassinât de patrick isoir
conserve toujours une part de mystère
[Musique]